Do you have investigated brain activity
during motor imagery in stroke patients
with hemiparesis and be paresis his,
his,
uh,
motor impairment from,
from uh,
from the stroke.
This work is exact aimed at examining
similarities between motor imagery and
execution.
In a group of stroke patients,
11 patients were asked to perform a
visual motor tracking task by either
physically or mentally tracking a sine
wave forest target using their thumb and
index finger.
So they're doing this
during FMRI scanning results.
Whole brain analysis confirmed shared
neural substrates between motor imagery
and motor execution and
bilateral premotor cortex.
So that's the part that
I was talking about.
I won't tell you about the
rest of the brain in pride.
A lobule.
This is partly associated
with body recognition.
So,
so basically I showed you
that study because it,
it,
it's one,
it's one of the studies that lend credence
to what I was just describing is that
imagery is the precursor to
action and that it's associated.
You get the imagery going
here and the action there.
Think about,
think about thanking think,
act.
That's roughly how it works.
Okay.
Now,
now down to cognitive ability.
Well,
how can you conceptualize intelligence?
Okay,
well this is a major problem because
your initial conceptualization determines
in part the strategies that you're going
to use to investigate intelligence.
And when you say,
when you,
when you pair a sentence
down to what is intelligence,
the sentence is problematic because
part of it is a question about
if and how such a thing might
manifest itself in the world.
So there's a fact out there that
are set of facts that corresponds to
intelligence.
But the other problem is,
well what do you mean
when you say intelligence?
And you kind of have to nail that down.
If you're going to have a coke
conversation about intelligence,
that doesn't go entirely astray.
And so you've got a,
you've got a definitional problem
as well as an empirical problem.
And so
there have been,
and this was especially true in the 1990s
people have been studying intelligence
Iq intelligence since the 1920s and it is
a very well established
branch of psychology.
One of the things I have
to tell you about it,
Iq research is that if
you don't buy Iq research,
you might as well throw away
all the rest of psychology.
And the reason for that
is that the psychologists,
first of all,
who developed intelligence testing
were among the early psychologists who
instantiated the statistical techniques
that all psychologists use to verify and
test all of their hypotheses.
So you end up throwing the baby out with
the bath water and the Iq people have
defined intelligence in a more stringent,
stringent and accurate way than we've
been able to define almost any other
psychological construct.
And so if you toss out the
one that's most well defined,
then you're kind of stuck with the problem
of what are you going to do with all
the ones that you have leftover that are
nowhere near as well defined or as well
measured or as,
or as or,
or who's predictive validity is much
less than it has been demonstrated with
much less vigor and clarity anyways,
despite all that people have posited a
number of different intelligences and
reasonably so because there's a,
if you think of intelligence as that
which might move you forward successfully
in the world,
obviously there's a fair number of
phenomena that are associated with
individuals that might
fit into that category.
So we have
people have made these distinctions.
Bob Sternberg for example,
is distinguished between practical versus
analytical intelligence and he kind of
thinks of practical as like street smarts
and has attempted to dissociate that
from the kind of analytical
intelligence that um,
that characterize this
more straight Iq research.
I don't think he's done it
successfully as well at all.
And since the 1990s interest in his
practical intelligence has declined
precipitously because when it is
matched head to head with standard Iq
intelligence,
the IQ intelligence seats
up pull the variability.
What's really happened as far as I can
tell so far is that when we're trying to
predict people's course through life,
Iq does a very good job and then one of
the traits does a very good job as well,
which is conscientiousness,
but it doesn't do as good a job as Iq.
Now that partly might be because we can't
measure conscientiousness very well.
We're stuck with self reports or maybe
I could gather peer reports about you or
I could gather your parents reports
about your teachers reports and each of
those seems to pick up a little bit
more of the pattern because you know
yourself,
but other people know you differently
than you know yourself and there's still
some accuracy in that.
You can get multiple rater reports of
something like conscientiousness and
that'll up.
It's predictive validity.
But in the final analysis,
the best you seem to be able to deal
with conscientiousness is about a 0.4
correlation with longterm performance.
Whereas with Iq in complex jobs,
you can probably get 0.5 and maybe
0.6 and so 0.5 is 25% of the variance.
You've got to square it.
Point six is 30% 36% of the variance
and 0.4 is 16% of the variance.
So even at the low end,
let's say high end for conscientiousness
is 0.4 or 16% low end for Iq is 0.5 or
25% low.
And estimates of Iq make it one and a
half times more powerful than the high end
estimates of.
And I think that's about right.
You'd think,
why do we even have to debate this?
And because it's so bloody obvious to me
that intelligence is a major predictor
of life success.
I mean you people,
I've measured the Iq of
University of Toronto people,
you know,
people in this room who have an
Iq of less than 120 are rare.
Well,
why?
smart people go to university now.
Is that actually a contentious statement?
What shouldn't be a contentious statement?
It's self evident.
Universities were actually set up so
that smart people could expand their
abilities.
That's why they were there.